that's right the Dark Knight Rises was
not the only thing to come out of this
weekend we also have a teaser trailer -
Man of Steel you don't know what that is
it's Superman dude and this teaser
trailer is a complete teaser trailer
comes out next year one year from now
and so you know it's going to be just
like alright here's kind of where we're
going with the movie you don't get
anything else after that not like The
Dark Knight Rises teaser trailer was
last year when Jim Gordon was just in
the battle like that's all it showed
that's kind of like that but I like the
tone that this sets up you're not just
anyone
one day you're gonna have to make a
choice mostly because right when the
trailer came on I was like that's Lord
of the Rings music really how can you
not think a Gandalf a light sigh you
fools cue the music
goblins all shooting arrows by their
heads yeah that's what I think of anyone
and this trailer shows Clark Kent in
this searching stage in his life you
know he's trying to find out who he is
how he's going to make a difference he's
all hitchhiking he's on Deadliest Catch
which right there he's making a big
difference what's the statistics on
boats like that like one person per boat
will die I think everyone on that boats
probably going to be safe the USS kal-el
is all business and I did not know there
were two versions of this trailer I mean
visually both the trailers are identical
but what's different is the voiceover
the voiceover and one is PAH Kent Kevin
Costner you have to decide what kind of
man you want to grow up to be whoever
that man is good character or bad the
voiceover and the other version of the
trailer is jor-el played by Russell
Crowe in time it will help them
accomplish wonders and the two
voiceovers have the same basic message
but Kevin Costner's is okay you need to
decide what to do Russell Crowe's is
you're going to do these great things so
one is choice the other is destiny both
are really cool and super mannish I love
them but I'm leaning towards Russell
Crowe the boys and Maximus Meridius it's
it's just cool or said six point seven
for people who remember fact that he
plays Superman's dad is just awesome
they got a really legit cast for this
movie I'm looking forward to it and of
course they cannot leave you with just
that you see Superman blasting into the
air breaking the sound barrier
that'd be great if you show some throw
the cellophane s off his chest in this
trailer wraps Zod's guy in it great yeah
if you didn't know here's the lowdown of
Man of Steel David s Goyer ster
co-writer of Batman Begins he wrote the
script for Man of Steel Christopher
Nolan you all know who he is if by off
chance you don't know who Christopher
Nolan is he is the director of the Dark
Knight trilogy and a few other sweet-ass
movies he is producing Man of Steel and
visual director Zack Snyder is directing
Man of Steel as long as he's directing
other people's work as long as he's not
the writer his work seems to be good
he's visually appealing and that's a
really cool direction to take Superman
not looking too shabby a teaser trailer
is pretty much a showcase for a tone I
like the tongue alright so the Man of
Steel trailer featuring Lord of the
Rings music which is just how you got to
do it if you're going to reintroduce
Superman to the world on the big screen
you do it with Lord of the Rings music
did you see it did you like it what did
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you